california is moving ahead with its
long-planned high-speed rail project
that one day may connect san francisco
to los angeles that's not going to
happen anytime soon but the project has
received enough funding to start work
and complete the central valley portion
that runs through the agricultural
heartland of the golden state
in 2008 california voters approved a 10
billion dollar bond measure to provide
the initial funding to build the first
high-speed rail system in the united
states at that time the project was
estimated to cost about 40 billion
dollars
that cost has ballooned dramatically to
complete the entire section between san
francisco down to la with stops in san
jose and other major cities in
california the expectation is it's going
to run about 105 billion dollars and
that cost could still increase
currently the program does have funding
to complete 171 miles a portion through
the central valley of california
it's not heavily populated and it's one
of the easier sections to build through
and even that has been a very difficult
challenge to get going
already about 119 miles are under
construction running through cities
including fresno bakersfield and
eventually connecting up to merced in
the north
however to really make the system
meaningful it's going to have to have
those connections into the san francisco
bay area and down into los angeles in
southern california
so far the state of california has
provided more than nine billion dollars
for the project additionally
the
federal bipartisan infrastructure law
does provide some additional funding for
the program so between two and three
billion dollars are likely
to flow into the project to help get
that central valley portion completed in
total the expectation is building just
that first 171 miles will run between 23
and 25 billion dollars
many of those costs also include
securing some of the last remaining
sections of land needed in the central
valley
however an additional 80 billion dollars
is likely to be needed to do the much
more difficult work of getting to san
francisco and los angeles because the
system's going to have to bore through
major mountain ranges including the
tehachapi and san gabriel range in
southern california
and it will also have to contend with
earthquake fault lines that that ring
the state of california including the
san andreas fault
these are not insurmountable engineering
challenges they've been conquered in
places like japan which is equally
mountainous and also
highly prone to earthquakes but it does
add a lot of cost so it's very unclear
at this point exactly where all of that
additional money is going to come from
and what the timeline is to complete the
entire system the united states is a bit
of a laggard when it comes to high-speed
rail
america does have passenger rail in the
form of amtrak and some commuter lines
but compared to japan china
most of europe and a lot of other parts
of the world high-speed rail is really
not a factor here just yet
we are a car-based country in part
that's because the united states is so
very large so cars and airplanes tend to
be a bit more practical in most cases
but there is a movement that is
building to add a lot more high-speed
rail in the united states these are
incredibly expensive projects to do
money is not readily available and they
also take a very very long time to plan
out and do the actual construction work
proponents of the california system see
an opportunity to connect all of the
california cities including those in the
central valley that were bypassed by the
state's interstate 5 freeway the main
connector between southern california
and the bay area
travel time between los angeles to san
francisco when the system's completed
could be under three hours compared with
five to seven to eight hours by car
currently
ridership figures are estimated to be
about 50 million passengers annually by
2040
which could generate more than 3 billion
dollars of fair revenue
currently funding for the system
to build it is coming from california's
cap and trade program which is
generating about a billion dollars that
flows into
the california high-speed rail project's
annual budget how long those funds will
be available
isn't entirely clear the project does
have funding for the time being but the
big question is whether it can
ultimately find all of that additional
money that it's going to need to achieve
those big ridership numbers that are
anticipated
one of the benefits
that proponents also see is it will
really connect the state of california
in a way that it's not connected today
one could live in fresno or bakersfield
and commute to work in los angeles or up
into silicon valley
housing prices are astronomical in
southern and northern california much
more reasonable in the central valley so
it's a way in which there might be it
might make it easier for people to live
in in california a bit more affordably
what we're seeing right now is a little
bit of optimism for the system there's
been a lot of pessimism over the last
few years because of cost overruns and
the reality of how long this project is
going to take to complete the fact that
it's now able to move forward with this
first section does provide some optimism
that this might actually happen there's
been a lot of doubt that it would
however base best case scenario
the system won't be fully operational
until the late 2030s that first section
in the central valley
should begin operating by about 20 30
approximately eight years from now
however that's a lightly populated
section of california ridership numbers
aren't expected to be terribly high in
those early years not until it connects
into san jose san francisco and los
angeles in the south will california
begin to see really meaningful ridership
numbers but again everything hinges on
finding tens of billions of dollars that
currently do not exist in its budget